[Music]
so I was so committed to being a jazz
musician and then I got braces and it
messed it up I couldn't play trumpet
anymore Oh cuz it's like that puckering
yeah it would cut into my mouth so I
couldn't really play and I got braces
from this I had an orthodontist who I
hated because he'd ruined my what I saw
is like a future Grammy winning jazz
career and he and his office had a
picture he was kind of a megalomaniac he
in his office had a picture of him
dressed as an orthodontist putting
braces on him
Brett dressed as Superman you can drop
the kinda that's insane yeah there's too
many fantasies happening there yeah
Superman was like I can do anything but
smile but confident and he couldn't just
be Superman it's not enough to be super
mean he has to be Superman and also
Superman's dentist he also had a a
wall-sized 3d mural of him putting
braces on all the animals in the jungle
even the beaver
I think the beaver was cued up he was
doing the lion but can't straighten the
lion's teeth yeah he needs them it's a
liability yeah it's a liability Oh
[Applause]
did we just have simultaneous strokes so
your dentist was a lunatic your
orthodontist was a lunatic yeah members
name I do we don't have to slander him I
don't yeah I'm scared I'm still a little
scared someone has the confidence to do
that has the confidence to track you
down you just you wake up in your bed
and you're dressed as Superman with
belts across you but then so I went my
parents who were kind of ludicrously
supportive we're like okay well we
understand you're anxious about jazz so
we're gonna take you to Wynton Marsalis
is dentist in New York so they took me
to weave them ourselves his dentist who
his name doctor chops he's a jazz he's a
jazz dentist you can just see it they're
like Miles Davis just like you gotta go
my first video game that I ever had was
a jazz video game what it was a jazz
video game you would wander through the
history of jazz there wasn't even any
like it was like there was no game it
was just you know and now I'm in the
south side of Chicago now I'm in
Storyville New Orleans it was like it
was basically like if grand theft auto
if instead of like hitting strippers
with crowbars you just quietly watch
Billy ha
[Music]